parlons maintenant de cinéma on
s'habitue à tout c'est ce que l'on
pourrait conclure après la projection
hier soir à Cann du film de Marco
Ferreri la Grande Bouffe dont nous vous
avons déjà parlé hier soir on nous avait
promis un scandale pour le film le plus
scandaleux de l'histoire du cinéma
finalement très peu de spectateurs ont
quitté la salle il y a eu bien sûr
quelques Hué des sifflés aussi des
applaudissements en tout cas le résultat
espéré par les producteurs est atteint
beaucoup de bruit autour de ce
film présente la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
France c'est un
scandale un
scandale ça gagne du poon ça sur le don
du pauvre
populo ou sous les mouvements divivers
comme l'ont dit Monsieur andréastou le
patron du cinéma français a congratulé
les acteurs dont de marelo mastroyani et
Michel picoli accompagné et réconforté
par leurs dames Catherine de neuve et
Juliette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Greco vous avez ainsi une idée des
réactions suscitées par la Grande Bouffe
ce film a réalisé une unanimité aussi
totale qu'ostile tant auprès des
spectateurs que de la critique ce qui
est tout de même assez rare au-delà du
style rabaisien ou pasolinien il y a
l'abject c'est semble-t-il ce que la
plupart des gens auront retenu après le
réalisme
outrancier de la Grande Bouffe Jacques
Brel propose aujourd'hui un voyage
poétique dans le monde de l'imaginaire
avec Far West c'est le droit de
RVER complètement en deh des en dehors
des normes en dehors de de la vie
quoi de
[Musique]
rêver c'est un message d'amour et
d'espoir film fraternel avec des
personnages à la recherche des valeurs
idéales et éphémères de l'enfance face
aux réalités d'aujourd'hui un film hors
de notre
[Musique]
temps qu'est-ce que vous avez voulu
également dire dans ce film c'est qu'il
y avait moyen qu'à qu'à 45 ans n'était
pas nécessairement un adulte qu'on
s'occupait pas nécessairement de de
pogon et de cul qu'on pouvait simplement
avir l'envie de de rêver d'être
naïvementlei
jeit 19
sieur en qu'est-ce que tu veux à ce
momentl jebé et toi où tu vas ah moi moi
je extraordinaire parce que ça vient
très exactement au lendemain d'un film
qui précisément montrait le contraire je
l'ai pas
vu qui se dépose sur nos
rid pour faire de nous vieux
enfants nous Revoil
jeunes
amant le cœur est
plein la tête et
VI de
l'enfance